>>> I AM HONORED THAT YOU HAVE
PUT YO TRUST IN ME TO CONTINUE
LEADING OUR BEAUTIFUL STATE.
I WILL BE A GOVERNOR FOR ALL
MICHIGANDERS AND WORK WITH
ANYONE WHO WANTS TO SOLVE
PROBLEMS AND GET THINGS DONE.
>> THAT WAS MICHIGAN'S
DEMOCRATIC GOVERNOR, GRETCHEN
WHITMER BEING SWORN IN YESTERDAY
FOR HIS SECOND TERM JUST DAYING
AFTER THE TWO MEN WERE SENTENCED
ON FEDERAL CHARGES IN THE PLOT
TO KIDNAP AND ASSASSINATE HER.
KAITLAN COLLINS GOT TO SPEND
TIME WITH THE GOVERNOR AT HER
HOME IN LANCING, MICHIGAN ON
INAUGURATION DAY AT THE
GOVERNOR'S MANSION.
HERE'S HER REPORTING.
>> SO THEY'VE ONLY EVER KNOWN
THE GOVERNOR'S MANSION.
>> THEY'VE ONLY KNOWN THIS
BEAUTIFUL PLACE, YES.
>> Reporter: INAUGURATION DAY
STARTS WITH CAN HEKIBBLE.
>> HOW ARE YOU FEELING TODAY?
>> I'M EXCITED, SECOND TERM.
WE HAVE A NEW LEGISLATURE, A
WHOLE NEW ENVIRONMENT HERE.
GOING TO GET SOME REALLY GOOD
STUFF DONE.
>> Reporter: IT'S 7:30 A.M., THE
GOVERNOR'S PUMPKIN OATMEAL BAKE
IS ON THE KITCHEN COUNTER AND
SHE'S SURROUNDED BY HER FAMILY.
SHE SAID SHE WASN'T ALWAYS
CONFIDENT THIS DAY WOULD COME.
>> THERE WAS SO MUCH CHAOS
POLITICALLY AND IN THE
ENVIRONMENT.
I DIDN'T KNOW IF I WOULD, YOU
KNOW, GET AN OPPORTUNITY TO
SERVE FOR FOUR MORE YEARS.
I NEVER IMAGINED I'D WIN BY
ALMOST 11 POINTS AND AND COME IN
WITH A NEW LEGISLATURE.
>> Reporter: WHITMER DEFEATED
HER OPPONENT DECISIVELY AND WITH
DEMOCRATIC CONTROL OF THE STATE
HOUSE AND SENATE FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN 45 YEARS IS VIEWING HER
TERM DIFFERENTLY.
>> DO YOU FEEL BATTLE TESTED?
>> IT'S HARD TO RATTLE ME NOW, I
WILL SAY THAT.
WE'VE HAD CHALLENGE AFTER
CHALLENGE.
BUT YEAH, I DO.
I'M MORE COMFORTABLE IN MY OWN
SKIN.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Reporter: TODAY STARTS HER
NEW TERM AND A NEW MISSION.
WHILE IT STILL INCLUDES FIXING
THE ROADS, WHITMER IS LEADING
THE PUBLIC CHARGE PROTECTING
ABORTION RIGHTS IN PART BECAUSE
OF HER OWN DAUGHTERS.
>> THEY BETTER BE ABLE TO MAKE
THEIR OWN DECISIONS ABOUT THEIR
BODIES AND HAVE PROTECTIONS
UNDER THE LAW.
THAT'S WHY, AS A MOM, SO MUCH OF
WHAT I DO IS DRIVEN BY MY OWN
SITUATION.
HAVING DAUGHTERS, I THINK IS --
MAKES IT SHARPER AND MORE URGENT
THAN IF I DIDN'T HAVE THEM.
>> Reporter: THOSE DAUGHTERS
DON'T ALWAYS LOVE HAVING THE
GOVERNOR AS MOM.
>> IT'S BEEN A LITTLE WEIRD, NOT
GOING TO LIE.
>> EVERYBODY KNOWS.
>> YEAH.
>> YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT
EVERYBODY SEES YOU ON THE
STREET, ON TINDER I SEE PICTURES
OF PEOPLE WITH MY MOTHER.
>> THAT'S WEIRD.
>> IT'S REALLY --
>> DO YOU -- ARE YOU LIKE,
THAT'S MY MOM?
>> NO, NO, NO.
>> NO!
>> SHE DOES NOT ADMIT.
>> Reporter: AS WHITMER'S
NATIONAL PROFILE HAS GROWN SO
HAVE THE THREATS AGAINST HER.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I'D BE LYING IF I TOLD YOU I'M
UNFAZED BY IT.
>> Reporter: WHITMER WAS SWORN
IN DAYS AFTER TWO MEN WHO LED
THE PLOT TO KIDNAP AND POSSIBLY
KILL HER WERE SENTENCED TO
PRISON.
>> 19 1/2 YEARS FOR ONE OF THE
ORGANIZERS OF THE CONSPIRACY TO
KIDNAP AND KILL ME, THAT IS A
SIGNIFICANT SENTENCE.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND, I'M AN ORDINARY
PERSON, I'VE GOT AN
EXTRAORDINARY JOB.
I HAVE SERVED IN EXTRAORDINARY
TIMES.
I'M A MOM, I'M A DAUGHTER, I'M
A -- AN AVERAGE PERSON TRYING TO
SERVE MY STATE.
>> Reporter: WHITMER HAS CHAFED
AS HOW THE MATTER HAS BEEN
DESCRIBED AS A KIDNAPPING PLOT
INSTEAD OF ASSASSINATION
ATTEMPT.
>> THEY WEREN'T PLANNING TO
RANSOM ME, THEY WERE GOING TO
KEEP ME AND ASSASSINATE ME.
THERE WAS ONE PERSON WHO SHOWED
UP ON, YOU KNOW, SUPREME COURT
JUSTICE'S LAWN AND TURNED
HIMSELF IN AND IT WAS COVERED AS
AN ASSASSINATION ATTEMPT.
>> THE ORDEAL MADE WHITMER
QUESTION REMAINING IN PUBLIC
SERVICE AND SHE WAS SHOCKED WHEN
HER OPPONENT USED IT AS A PUNCH
LINE ON THE DETAIL.
>> GRETCHEN WHIT MER IS GOOD AT
TAKING BUSINESSES FOR HOSTAGE
AND HOLDING IT FOR RANSOM.
>> WHAT WENT THROUGH YOUR MIND?
>> HOW CRAVEN AND HOW THERE ARE
SOME PEOPLE WHO CARE MORE ABOUT
WINNING AN ELECTION THAN THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF OUR
DEMOCRACY AND OUR FELLOW
AMERICANS.
>> Reporter: AS WHITMER TAKES
HER OATH OF OFFICE AND BEGINS
HER SECOND TERM, IT WILL ALSO BE
HER LAST DUE TO TERM LIMITS.
>> I DO THINK PEOPLE CAN HAVE
SOME GREAT TAKEAWAYS FROM WHAT
WE DID AND REPLICATE IT IN OTHER
STATES.
THE BEST WAY I CAN CONTRIBUTE TO
THE NATIONAL DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS
BE ABLE TO BE SOMEONE THEY CAN
POINT TO AND SAY THIS IS WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN YOU ELECT
DEMOCRATS.
>> Reporter: BUT THE GOVERNOR
BRUSHED OFF SPECULATION SHE'LL
SEEK A FUTURE WHITE HOUSE BID.
>> I'LL BE HONEST WITH YOU,
KAITLAN, I HAVE NOT SPENT A LOT
OF TIME THINKING ABOUT THAT, NO.
>> YOU SPENT SOME TIME THINKING
ABOUT IT?
>> BECAUSE PEOPLE ASK ME.
SO BRIEFLY.
>> Reporter: SO WHAT'S NEXT IN
FOUR YEARS WHEN SHE LEIAVES THE
GOVERNOR'S MANSION?
>> I'LL STAY ENGAGED IN ONE WAY
OR ANOTHER, I DON'T KNOW IF I'LL
RUN FOR ANYTHING BUT I'LL BE
ENGAGED.
>> SHE SAID IT BEFORE.
>> WHEN I LEFT THE LEGISLATURE,
EIGHT YEARS AGO, I NEVER THOUGHT
I WOULD RUN FOR OFFICE AGAIN.
I KNOW ENOUGH ABOUT MYSELF TO
KNOW IF THERE IS SOMETHING THAT
NEEDS TO GET DONE AND THERE'S A
ROLE I CAN PLAY, I WILL WANT TO
PLAY IT.
>> DO SWEAR OR AFFIRM --
>> Reporter: FOR NOW THE KNOW
C
FOCUS REMAINS ON THE JOB SHE WAS
JUST SWORN IN TO DO, GOVERNOR
FOR THE STATE OF MICHIGAN.
>> I HAVE NO PLANS OTHER THAN TO
SPEND THE NEXT FOUR YEARS
SERVING THE STATE AS GOVERNOR,
WITH A DEMOCRATIC MAJORITY FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN A LONG TIME
AND TO GET THINGS DONE HERE IN
MICHIGAN.